Les trous noirs
Off 1. Les trous noirs sont les objets les
plus extrêmes de l’astrophysique. Ces objets
incroyablement denses courbent l’espace-temps
si violemment, que même la lumière ne peut
pas leur échapper. Les trous noirs défient
l’intuition et capturent l’imaginaire.
C’est pour ça que des millions de personnes
se sont enfermés volontairement trois heures
dans une salle noire pour mieux les contempler.
Pour moi, le fait que même des non-physiciens
aiment penser et parler de ces objets est
un succès fantastique de la vulgarisation
scientifique, que je suis le premier à célébrer
! Les trous noirs font partis de la culture
populaire. Et ça, c’est super trop cool
!
Mais… mais il y a, du coup, beaucoup d’imprécisions
qui sont dites à ce sujet. Et aujourd’hui,
à l’instar de ce que j’ai pu faire dans
des épisodes précédents, je vais un petit
peu débunker 5 idées reçues sur les trous
noirs. Et pour ce faire, on va faire simple.
Je vais ainsi ignorer toutes les considérations
issues de la thermodynamique, de la mécanique
quantique ou encore de la théorie des cordes.
Aujourd’hui, on se concentre sur les trous
noirs de la relativité générale.
Off 2. Idée fausse numéro 1 : les trous
noirs sont des objets astrophysiques qui aspirent
tout, tels des aspirateurs cosmiques de l’espace-temps.
Pas vraiment. Si vous remplaciez le Soleil
par un trou noir avec la même masse que le
Soleil, les orbites des planètes du système
solaire seraient inchangées. Bon, il ferait
un peu frisquet sur Terre. Mais à part ça,
rien de changé. En particulier, la Terre
ne serait pas plus aspirée par le trou noir
qu’elle ne l’était par le Soleil.
Ceci dit, il y a un petit peu de vrai dans
l’idée selon laquelle les trous noirs “aspirent
plus” que le Soleil, dans le sens suivant.
Il existe une ré gion juste en dehors de
l’horizon des événements du trou noir
dans laquelle tout objet en chute libre finit
par tomber dans le trou noir. On l’appelle
“innermost stable circular orbit”. Plus
précisément, dans cette région qui n’existe
qu’en relativité générale, il n’y a
pas d’orbite circulaire stable. Cette propriété
que les trous noirs partagent avec d’autres
objets ultra-denses comme les étoiles à
neutrons. Donc on peut considérer que des
objets très proches du trou noir “aspirent”
plus les objets vers les trous noirs qu’une
étoile.
Off 3. Idée fausse numéro 2 : quiconque
proche d’un trou noir est broyé par la
gravité extrême qui y règne.
Je me souviens notamment d’un épisode de
Stargate SG1 où une équipe est en panique
car elle voit un trou noir dans le ciel. L’épisode
est vraiment cool… mais c’est pas grâce
à sa justesse scientifique…
En effet, près de certains trous noirs, la
gravité y est extrême. Mais attention à
ce que l’on entend par gravité ! Il ne
s’agit pas là de l’accélération des
référentiels. Si vous tombez dans un trou
noir en chute libre, vous suivez alors une
ligne droite de l’espace-temps. Et donc,
vous ne subissez aucune accélération. Et
donc ce n’est absolument pas une force de
pesanteur qui vous tuera à l’approche d’un
trou noir. En chute libre, il n’y a pas
de force de pesanteur.
Si vous risquez de mourir, c’est à cause
d’une courbure de l’espace-temps extrême.
Comment se manifeste-t-elle sur vous ? Et
bien, comme j’en ai déjà parlé de manière
newtonienne dans les commentaires de l’épisode
17, et comme j’en ai déjà parlé de manière
Einsteinienne dans l’épisode Hardcore et
les commentaires de l’épisode 21, cette
courbure de l’espace-temps correspond à
l’effet de marée. Elle nous étire dans
la direction radiale, c’est-à-dire celle
qui nous aligne avec le trou noir, et nous
contracte dans la direction orthogonale, la
direction dite orthoradiale. Et donc, si vous
tombez les pieds en avant dans un trou noir,
la courbure de l’espace-temps va vous étirer
dans la hauteur, et vous contracter dans la
largeur. C’est ce que l’on appelle la
spaghettification.
Cette spaghettification, vous la subissez
quotidiennement quand vous vous tenez debout
sur Terre. Mais elle est ultra, ultra faible.
Qu’en est-il près d’un trou noir ? Et
bien, ça dépend de la taille du trou noir.
Dans l’épisode Hardcore, on avait calculé
l’accélération à laquelle l’espace-temps
éloigne votre tête de vos pieds. Si on dit
que vous êtes proche du trou noir et que
vous faites, en ordre de grandeur, 1 mètre
de haut, cette accélération est à peu près
égale à 1mètre * c^2 / R_S^2, où R_S est
ce que l’on appelle le rayon de Schwarzschild,
et c’est, en gros, le rayon du trou noir.
On peut le calculer avec l’équation R_S
= 2GM/c^2. Donc si on remplaçait notre Soleil
par un trou noir de même masse, on aurait
R_S ≈ 3 kilomètres. Si vous êtes prêt
de ce trou noir, votre tête s’éloignerait
de votre pied avec une accélération astronomique
de 1mètre * c^2 / R_S^2 ≈ 10 milliards
de mètres par secondes carré, soit un milliard
de fois l’accélération à laquelle le
sol se rapproche d’une pomme. Là, croyez-moi,
vous mangez. Et vous ne survivrez pas.
Mais si le trou noir en question est maintenant
le trou noir supermassif au centre de la voie
lactée. Le rayon de Schwarzschild de ce trou
noir est R_S = 2 millions de milliards de
mètre. Du coup, l’accélération qui éloignerait
votre tête de votre pied près de ce trou
noir supermassif sera de l’ordre de 1mètre
* c^2 / R_S^2 ≈ 20 millionième de milliardièmes
de mètre par seconde carré. À titre de
comparaison, on avait calculé que, sur Terre,
l’éloignement de votre tête par rapport
à vos pieds à la surface de la Terre était
de 3 millionièmes de mètres par seconde
carré. Et cette accélération, on l’a
dit, elle est ultra négligeable. Donc vous
imaginez bien qu’une accélération un milliard
de fois moindre sera archi négligeable ! En
fait, si vous entrez dans le trou noir supermassif
au centre de la voie lactée, vous ne vous
rendrez compte de rien. Absolument rien. Il
n’y aura pas de pancarte pour vous dire
: “Bienvenue dans le trou noir de la voie
lactée, désolé pour les effets de la courbure
de l’espace-temps sur votre santé”. Notamment
car cette courbure de l’espace-temps n’aura
aucun effet sur votre santé. Entre autres…
Off 4. Idée fausse numéro 3 : Les trous
noirs sont des régions de l’espace desquels
rien n’échappe.
Les trous noirs ne sont en fait pas des régions
de l’espace. Mais… wait for it… ce sont
des régions de l’espace-temps ! En fait,
les trous noirs sont des ensembles d’événements
de l’espace-temps infiniment loin dans le
futur. Et c’est pour ça que rien ne peut
échapper de ces trous noirs. Car pour sortir
d’un trou noir, il faudrait surtout remonter
le temps !
Pour comprendre ceci, il nous suffit ici de
comprendre que le temps près d’un trou
noir est très ralenti, comme on en a déjà
parlé dans l’épisode 23. Une heure près
d’un trou noir correspond ainsi à des années
loin du trou noir. Et plus on est prêt du
trou noir, plus cet effet de dilatation gravitationnelle
du temps est important. Vous pouvez en savoir
plus avec l’épisode Hardcore.
En fait, si on observait un ballon de foot
tomber en tournant sur lui-même dans un trou
noir, on verrait ce ballon tourner de moins
en moins vite. Le temps finirait même par
être tellement indéfiniment ralenti que
le ballon finirait par devenir immobile, et
se figerait au niveau de l’horizon du trou
noir. En fait, ce qu’il se passe vraiment,
c’est que rien ne tomberait dans le trou
noir. Tout se figerait à l’horizon du trou
noir.
Enfin, ça, c’est ce que l’on voit, nous
qui restons à l’extérieur du trou noir.
Mais un enfant qui accompagnerait le ballon,
lui, s’il traverse l’horizon du trou noir,
il verrait le ballon avoir traversé le trou
noir aussi. Est-ce qu’il n’y a pas là
une contradiction ? Et bien non ! Ce qu’il
se passe, c’est qu’en traversant le trou
noir, l’enfant a fait un bond énorme dans
un futur si lointain, qu’il est plus lointain
que notre futur le plus lointain. Il a atteint
un temps qui est au-delà de notre espace-temps.
BOOM !
Off 5. Idée fausse numéro 4 : Les trous
noirs sont si massifs, que même la lumière
ne peut pas leur échapper. Et d’ailleurs,
c’est pour ça que les trous noirs sont
noirs.
Ça, c’est une idée du 18ème siècle.
Et oui, l’idée du trou noir, c’est pas
une idée ultra-moderne. Laplace y avait déjà
pensé, en raisonnant à partir du principe
de vitesse de libération, dont Science Étonnante
a parlé ici. Mais gardez en tête que ce
que David dit dans la vidéo est très newtonien.
Et oui, parce que dans sa vidéo, David ne
s’adresse pas à des gens qui sont censés
avoir déjà regardé 23 vidéos sur la relativité
générale… Ceci dit, je vous invite très
fortement à aller lire les précisions relativistes
qu’il a ajoutées dans le billet de blog
associé à la vidéo…
Bref, la description des trous noirs par Laplace
ou par David correspondent à une vision newtonienne
de la gravité. Bon il se trouve que, par
hasard, les formules se ressemblent beaucoup.
Mais il ne s’agit que d’une coincidence.
En fait, le rayon de Schwarzschild n’a pas
d’interprétation géométrique simple.
Car le rayon du trou noir, techniquement,
n’est pas le rayon de Schwarzschild. C’est
le rayon de la représentation du trou noir
dans la carte de Schwarzschild de l’espace-temps.
Mais les distances sur cette carte ne sont
pas les distances dans l’espace-temps. Encore
une fois, si vous voulez en savoir plus, il
va falloir vous taper l’épisode Hardcore…
Bref. Tout ça pour dire que les intuitions
newtoniennes des trous noirs ne sont pas valides.
En particulier, si les trous noirs sont noirs,
ce n’est pas parce que la lumière ne peut
pas leur échapper. En fait, quand on regarde
un trou noir, on voit surtout la matière
figée au niveau de l’horizon des événements.
Cette lumière, notamment si elle est chauffée,
n’a aucune raison d’être noire. Mais
à cause de la dilatation du temps, la lumière
de cette matière figée est très décalée
vers le rouge. Si décalée vers le rouge
qu’elle n’est plus observable. En fait,
la lumière qui nous vient de l’horizon
des événements est même infiniment décalée
vers le rouge ! Et c’est pour ça que les
trous noirs sont noirs !
Off 6. Idée fausse numéro 5 : les trous
noirs ont une densité infinie.
Non. En tout cas pas les trous noirs supermassifs.
En fait, un trou noir est déterminé par
le paramètre de compacité \Xi = GM/c^2R.
En particulier, il est en M/R, alors que la
densité de la matière correspond au facteur
M/R^3. Du coup, les trous noirs supermassifs
correspondent à des densités très faibles.
La densité du trou noir au centre de la voie
lactée est d’environ 37 milliardièmes
de celle de l’eau. En gros, il est surtout
vide, ce trou noir…
Mais il y a encore plus étrange. Techniquement,
un trou noir pourrait exister, même s’il
était vide. Oui, vous avez bien entendu.
L’équation de Schwarzschild qui décrit
les trous noirs sans rotation est une solution
des équations de la relativité générale
d’Einstein dans le vide. Du coup, si l’on
en croît Schwarzschild, on n’a pas besoin
de matière pour déformer l’espace-temps.
On n’a même pas besoin d’énergie ! Tout
ce qui importe dans l’équation de Schwarzschild,
c’est le rayon de Schwarzschild, qui a lui
tout seul, sans besoin de masse, dicte à
l’espace-temps la courbure qu’impose le
trou qu’il décrit…
Alors, il s’agit peut-être uniquement d’une
bizarrerie mathématique… Mais dans l’Histoire
de la physique, il y a eu tellement de bizarreries
mathématiques qui ont fini par être des
inspirations profondes à l’origine de grandes
découvertes…
À refaire :
Danser de joie
Dans le cas des trous noirs en rotation, on
trouve des trajectoires encore plus étranges
à proximité d’un trou noir. Je vous invite
à aller voir l’excellente vidéo de Passe-Science
pour en savoir plus, ou le blog de Dr Goulu.
Mais considérons le trou noir supermassif
appelé Sagittarius A (étoile), qui se trouve
pas loin du centre de notre galaxie. Ce trou
noir a un rayon de Schwarzschild de 26 mille
années-lumières, soit 10^10 mètres. L’effet
de marée, c’est-à-dire l’accélération
relative de votre tête par rapport à vos
pieds causée par la courbure de l’espace-temps,
est d’environ 1 millième de mètres par
secondes carrés. C’est 10 000 fois moins
que l’accélération du sol vers le haut
sur Terre. Autant dire que l’effet de marée
aux abords des trous noirs supermasifs est
ultra négligeable.
Pour un trou noir, le rayon de Schwarzschild
est proportionnel à la masse du trou noir,
donc le rapport M/R_S est une constante. Mais
la densité d’un corps est proportionnelle
à M/R_S^3. Du coup, la densité des trous
noirs décroît avec le carré de leur taille.
Si les petits trous noirs vont être bien
denses, ce n’est pas le cas de trous noirs
supermassifs. En fait, Sagittarius A (étoile)
a un rapport M/R_S^3 de l’ordre de la densité
de l’eau. Et on imagine bien que certains
trous encore plus supermassifs seront encore
moins denses.
Je mets un petit bémol à ce que je viens
de dire. Le rayon de Schwarzschild n’est
pas tout à
fait le “rayon” du trou noir. C’est
certes ce qu’obtiendrait un observateur
lointain s’il multipliait la taille angulaire
du trou noir par
la distance qui le sépare du trou noir. C’est
aussi le rayon de la région de la carte de
l’espace-temps qui lui correspond dans la
carte
de l’espace-temps de Schwarzschild dont
on a parlé
dans l’épisode Hardcore. Mais comme les
distances autour du trou noir sont incroyablement
déformées, et elles le sont encore plus
à “l’intérieur du trou noir”. Bref.
Prenez ce que je viens de dire sur la densité
des trous noirs
avec des pincettes. Quoiqu’il en soit, …